please welcome the very talented lauren
cohen how are you
i'm good yeah you say my name right
conan
people don't have a few people people
say
cohen right and when i was younger and i
tried to correct them i said
cohen and they all said like conan the
barbarian and i was like well that's not
my preferred
reference but sure and then uh yeah like
a
shitty nickname well i was um i was you
know
a teenager when the conan the barbarian
movie came out
and my life uh was hell
but the only uh upside to it was that i
had to get i got in so many fights
that i developed the same physique as
the actual cone of the barbarian
and um i've kept it to this day i just
and the accent thank you yeah
that's right so good of you to know this
you know it's funny because i um i do
feel
very comfortable talking to you because
i talked to you
uh when you were first on the walking
dead
i think i think i might have been one of
the first shows that you came on
and obviously you were you're just a
very nice real person
so we got along right away but i
remember thinking when i first talked to
you
i don't think you'd been doing the show
that long at all you were kind of a
newbie
yeah kind of a newbie you were my first
talk show experience
legitimately it was the first and it was
it was very easy i will say
and i think that you reenacted a kill
with me
i think that it was right around the
time when our group was doing like a lot
of
you know yeah we were suddenly sort of
deluged by a bunch of new zombies
and uh and yeah it was it was fun it was
like
it's crazy to think about it that was
like 10 years ago i know um
yeah and yet still i'm only in my
mid-30s
uh don't laugh at that i'm going to edit
that laugh out
did you notice did you notice that
when i mean you've been doing it for a
while when you first
started okay and you're brand new on
walking dead and you have to kill a
zombie
was your technique different than
say it is now that you're you're a pro
yeah because you have to keep yourself
entertained right so i'm just
i'm almost embarrassed by my like super
basic zombie kill skills from the
beginning
because they were just you know the
machete or just like
you know the the what would you even
call it if you're here like a
shish kebab shish kebab yeah i like to
shish kebab
yeah yeah yeah for and and that doesn't
even have to be for somebody
called bob i mean that can be for any
any name zombie
and and then we do like the the hearing
aid if you have like from ear to ear you
just do like a little scoop right
through
um so when these new people come i try
to tell them
to use these and i give them names and
um
nobody nobody uses the names it's it's
weird they just
they don't they don't stick i could be
uh
mine would be the puree what i would do
is i would grab a zombie
and i would force his head into a
professional chef's blender
and then i would push puree and i would
puree the zombie's head for
25 seconds until it was a nice froth and
then i would pour that froth
on top of like a a latte
and right right or freeze it into little
ice cubes so that when you have your
whiskey cocktail
you can have a giant a giant cube of
your ideas your idea is much better your
idea is much more
no no no i like your idea better because
alcohol is involved so
right you took it up you took it up a
notch and i appreciate that
we actually um someone on my staff has
way too much time
on his hands and he put together a
montage
of your zombie kills and this is a true
testament
to your abilities as a true warrior
let's take a look
there's the shish kebab there's the
shish kebab oh my god
waffle maker oh that was a waffle maker
oh oh this is a obey street sign
you need more you know what's crazy and
this says something sad about me
i could watch that all day
and especially if you're having a bad
day and you have a lot of unresolved
anger
i when i when i watch walking dead and
you guys
take out 35 zombies in two seconds i
come down to dinner with my wife and
kids
and i'm so zen i feel
i feel you relieved you it's been a
cathartic experience
all my childhood people yeah exactly
they are people but luckily there's a
you know there's there's sort of an
allowance in your mind for
for the fact that yeah you're also
freeing them
of being the undead that's the way i
look at it yeah
you're doing them a favor you're doing
them yeah they don't want to be
looking for food no no the fact that
they seem upset when you kill them
doesn't make any sense but we'll work on
that